okay so uh part two for this round I get
to surprise Doug so we are going to do
wait for it wait for Bubba oh oh oh time
up
Oh Congo diamonds aren't here and queer
and that's going anywhere now they're
officially not ah this is right after
they legalized gay marriage so all right
after were a few days at I know but I'm
still so Adair's jello freaked out
no no I deservingly so I know anywhere
when I can make this uh political but
it's not it's not a great week for
bigots I gotta say it's been it's kind
of one to blow with the Confederate flag
is that's just oh man uh yeah it's uh
it's wonderful okay okay I'm sorry
I'm still riding that high it's like
it's just it really is something dancing
but okay so now you're gonna be farting
rainbows puking unicorns uh as was
predicted in the Bible
look watch we're gonna get spammed with
them the Bible quote same so uh but it's
uh I much argue if they're said by Tim
Curry in that accent I'm okay and yeah
and all I am show lead um what the what
if ye she be violated then you may buy
her for fifty shekels you must wear
tiny'mons
oh I got it there is some stuff in this
movie you know when we saw this movie we
came it was gonna be bad and he does
again sign of the beginning God on the
big screen yeah because I write the book
I know my Crichton fit I read have a
book and I was liking it so I was
enjoying it it's uh well Michael cranes
ghost is like you know hey you leave the
movie alone oh damn no I don't my guess
is he didn't like that movie I'm pretty
sure um yeah I don't know I don't know
where to start with this solid actors in
this movie and I will say like the good
one
Mosel the most amazing being bruce
campbell yeah all of like a minute ago
if you want a great time read his his
autobiography if chins could kill
because he talks about congo how like
this is a greatest trip ever i just went
across the country to all these exotic
locales I ate a cameo basically and you
know basically I'm there and uh do
nothing but sit around enjoy my time
work maybe add a boom I've done my say
oh I'm doing this um but yeah
everybody's we all have two totally
other Congo story that he tells later by
that but yet Bruce Campbell Ernie Hudson
Tim Curry uh Laura Linney is earning
yeah uh you know the great I think Ernie
Hudson the light it should be the
legendary Tim Curry in the great Ernie
Hudson because Ernie Hudson is one of
those actors and the legitimately
incredible morally no he's just
Ernie Hobbes is just so yeah and and the
completely adequate Lora Mae um
she's amazing okay I know anytime she's
not in this movie
um she's doing her best though I mean oh
she's doing her best very morally the
movies does her no face yeah um but
Ernie Hudson just in anything is just
God he's so fucking awesome and like I
said I feel like he doesn't get enough
respect he's like oh the fourth
Ghostbuster odd this but he just shows
up in things I he should have been once
upon a time for just a bit role
basically and I'm like Ernie Hudson yes
please let my wife loved this new show
on Netflix with Lily Tomlin and Jane
Fonda and it's it's not bad it's just
not my face you try to give me a watch
my up to I'm just like yeah I'm giving
it to this but then I saw Ernie Hudson
was in episode I'm like yes and it's
like anytime he's out of just like shit
you're awesome you are so awesome
uh you know it's not just like oh you
were Ghostbuster so I had to think
you're great that's like no he is
legitimately awesome and really if you
want proof of that watch him just save
this performance in this movie he is so
charismatic you know cool he has a
gravitas yes uh he just has a gravitas
to everything that he does and he is
I mean it's tough I objectively speaking
I would say he's the best thing in this
movie because he's for the most part
playing it straight whereas Tim Curry is
not but if I'm going for most hilarious
performance Tim Curry wins but the two
of them are dueling in this Mia for
who's is giving you the best performance
um but yeah we said temporaries is
probably like the most enjoyable and how
goofy it is but Ernie Hudson is kind of
like I would legitimately follow you if
you existed in real life like if this
situation was heaven you live with
there's a gun you sons of bitches try to
take over the world it's amazing just
like I'm with you I'm totally following
you this guy could have been blade yeah
you could have forget it would have been
a little different than Wesley Snipes
take on it but I could totally see it
because he just sells it
um there's one thing out then vent I'm
like what like me like me haha he's
really Clark Gable yet yeah but but
really the best way I mean it's not to a
boyhood god damn it slams into like ah
Z's night uh it's not to a point where
it's like you know you can kind of laugh
at a little bit but it's legitimately
charming and cool he is very much the
black guy in charge surrounded by idiots
like that's whenever I see him in that
movie it's like yeah I'm just like I'm
like you were the guy in charge you're
surrounded by morons you have to lead
these clowns through the middle of the
jungle I'm like I would follow this dude
I would totally do it that's how much i
buy this guy's performance and I Ernie
Hudson he's amazing but you know most
actors can't open a can of sardines so I
I find that highly unlikely he could do
that in real life but I believe he could
uh yeah I think you know I read the I
read the book to a grown really on your
recommendation oh the dress we parked I
know it's it's a good book it's not his
greatest it's very much a page-turner no
yeah but it's like in action I mean in a
sense kind of like what this movie
wanted to be it's a good action kind of
like I want say almost like a b-movie
book almost but like but it's but like
traffic park it's cool it's a cool book
and uh always Crichton was always great
with cool ideas and making it
interesting enough that you just want to
flip the page like what's going to
happen he constructed his plots very
well now his Achilles heel is he
couldn't write a likable character to
save his fucking life but every
character in a cretin book is a d-bag
Kongo no income kinda way to works yeah
it works that they're all you know
dressed and that's why it doesn't work
here
like Laura Linney is suppose because I
thought you're ascending on for this
reason I think it's like no you should
be the carnet bitch that's going there
just you know the book change in total
bit yeah it wasn't in the mall yeah and
I liked her in the book because she was
just fuckin hard I sound like a Sarah
Connor in the book well yeah shades in
the head is like let's go and they just
go out there you know it's not some
fucking monkeys yes there's even one
even in the book there's one part like
during the hippo attack like they say
you know and and she screamed I was just
like the way I'm seeing this character
would not scream like maybe I had even
higher expectations for the alright but
whoever an N on the receiving end of a
hippo well not bad man
- fuckin I'd scream like Bruce Campbell
evil this you know me nobody even
they're like I think I just had like
this idea for like you know like it was
so raised high up that even even in the
book I was kinda like oh no she'd do
that and that's the author saying it and
I again see resume is like cranes point
of views that they're almost always
either scientists or businessmen people
who generally don't have a sense of
humor um you know not always relatable
very Vulcan Mike and that always makes
his books both interesting because they
tend to be hardcore but they're not
really relatable to normal human beings
every time and that was the one thing
about Jurassic Park that's interesting
is how the movie the one thing kept and
Spielberg did that was the saving grace
for the movie um as it was was they made
the characters more relatable because
they're not ham it's a fuckin asshole on
the boy/girl asshole got buck gets his
frickin neck chewed on shitter like rat
I mean not like enjoyable cutesy
friendly oh he's so bright
keys are in the movie he's not grandkids
in the book like he's fuckin a yeah
they're playing around with the computer
and like he's like those damn kids why
don't I ever bring him he's like
thinking this I'm like wow they're all
nasty oh yeah so that is is a Kiwi seal
and this movie that was one of its
problems is I think Worley yeah I she's
not his hardcore the the guy playing I
forget his name is not written us our
core to her but of the gorilla handler
um I thought I just was not seeing that
as his character I thought he was way
too nice that the ending is completely
fucking Hollywood schmaltz horse shit
compared to the book as with most crime
books it ends on this ambiguous like
well life sucks fair we got there's um
you know where's the movies like new Amy
go into the wild like yes so bad but at
least a dig again any one go that stupid
thing wasn't in it and like I'm sorry I
know they wanted to give away for the
the ape to talk but between the sign
language the ape effects
um which normally I just was Rick Baker
right I want to say I wanna say whoever
I don't know I want to say was Rick
Baker but I was at Stan Winston Oh
Winston it may have a Winston who it was
one of the big one it was one of the big
brain wasn't one of the big grades and
they don't look very happy
yeah and and it's like and I love them
so much this is not too insulting but
that was the everybody has their off day
and this was like an off day because I'm
like for not for a second I'm like no
it's a gorilla suit - Natalie I could
not buy it for a single second and the
idea I know they wanted the ate to talk
because in the book she's signing and
Crichton just simply wrote out the words
yeah that you visually you need you know
something you need oh yeah but to to
very long zoo but the voice just just
kills it I'm like this is it's like
giving this gorilla that you're supposed
to kind of take seriously the voice of
Jake wood from Phantom Menace
it's so silly just silly a planet yeah
it's like you know it's like spending an
entire movie with a fucking giant
gorilla version of Elmo okay
I can't I was like the second I heard
the ape talk I'm like no I like please
tell me that setting one and I got your
settings in eventually event she's gonna
the names go talk like Stephen Hawking
at least or something like come on nope
no whole movie I'm so glad I let you
pick this movie cuz this uh more about
than I probably could and this is a fun
movie to make fun of um but at to this
movies credit they did create Tim Curry
and those little Santosh I know what am
i called the diamonds are here that's it
yeah be he wasn't in the book you know
that was only funny like we get to occur
in the role it's like electric it's like
he's doing one of his cartoon character
yeah no you totally yeah it's almost
like he's just voice acting oh yeah
maybe he thought he was gonna be
replaced by some CGI monkeys oh shit I
was on camera the whole time um but and
it's funny because he doesn't Russian
accent here but in the Hunt for Red
October he's a pretty much just doing
his British a silly other rubbish and
soda know we we need people to take this
movie seriously just do the British ass
yeah I don't anybody doing a Russian
accent in that movie I think they're all
just the normal yellow you know it would
just to their crows are very smart I
think Sam I think sam neill was trying
to do a slight accent but anyway so it
just one of the great performs and one
of the great throwaway lines we've ever
heard
stop eating my sesame cake
that guy's a lot fine action like it's a
totally pointless see but it's like
again it's okay cuz you just you have
this character actor who's just gonna go
totally not to know that it's just gonna
be like the director because ee i don't
know what i'm doing it's like just do
whatever you want oh we're such a scary
kind of action-packed book the best
parts of the movie are not the action no
it's just letting these idiot characters
interact with each other it was kind of
cool seeing the the laser at the end
that was kind of neat those
that just to let you know legs are
supposed to do it just like zoom just
like an limbs gone like it a millisecond
and this is one of those this is one of
those things where what works on paper
does not always work on film because
like let's look about this about the
evil giant gray killer apes I'm like
this pretty fuck it's stupid
I mean this is Bhima but imagining it
it's kind of awesome even I feel under
their house Michael crying is that
fucking good um it works you're like
reading it really oh okay like you think
first thing that's kind of dumb but I
want to know what happens well what I
like about funny in the movie it just
doesn't work you take one look at the
costumes they're like no well what I
like about crying is that you forget
you're reading kind of this b-movie like
you get sucked in to kind of like the
atmosphere he's so great writing this
and well he's a master and you've read
purpose oh yes most of his ideas are
based on older ideas it's not like an
India Jones hat did that too like you
almost forget you're watching a b-movie
because you like the action these
characters never even this old Jurassic
Park is a ripoff his own book quest for
yeah so which is why every was flipping
out about dres but it's like West world
webs like so is Jurassic Park um but you
know and and sphere you know is very
much like Forbidden Planet and but I
mean this is what he does and he doesn't
really well my thing is like you can
tell the same story again and again if
you do it really well and he does the
movie does not nor does fear them okay
um it's it's pretty terrible but it's
kind of hilariously terrible it's really
enjoyable II just
it's batshit crazy bad it do a lot of
fun you know if you watch the Siskel and
Ebert review of this they have a big
disagreement whether or not it was meant
to be bad and I think I want to say they
both didn't like it but they like
wellness clothes I made one like it
because they thought it was supposed to
be bad and it's an interesting argument
because it's kinda like yeah like I
can't tell I really can't tell if it was
intentional because this wasn't Frank
Marshall I think directed it you know
he's done some stuff and he's mostly a
producer we straight to some stuff and
it's like with him it's
like yeah he's directed some good stuff
it's also kind of corny it's kind of
like the Robertson Mecca thing we know
it's good but it's kind of you know a
little schmaltzy and whimsical hammering
and stuff so you kind of don't know
whether or not this is meant to be taken
seriously or not but what about it I'm
not believing the Russian accent picking
up on that like whether it is or not
it's a lot of fun for how incredibly
stupid it
heywood my vision wish if I my only hope
is that if I were a director and I heard
Tim Curry's accent even for seconds I
would have been like okay this is meant
to be bad like otherwise I would have
said that it has to be a comedy shit a
brick and thought my career is over like
because it's just you you can't take it
seriously I don't know how you're
supposed to take that seriously and I
love Tim Curry and that's Tim Curry's
kind of like this is what that's
impossible good is no bad he's like
Christopher Walken he's like so good and
so bad and such a just he's like
Schwarzenegger too like just a force of
nature
you bring him on set you don't know what
the hell you're gonna get today but but
but two tuples in the walk-ins credit
they can actually add we see no no no
I'm at a million movies attachment line
one a little bit just so bad Jimmy is no
wonder if you wish does he meant to be
bad because I just if it was meant to be
taken seriously I would like Tim down
haha take take that accent you know take
it from 11:00 turn it down to one like I
would have said something unless maybe
that was him taking it from 11:00 to
1:00 I don't know well I heard something
like the Bruce Campbell sort of saying
there's some sort of contract that like
the writer had were every line of
Dalisay that's true but you would think
like wasn't that how movies work it not
no wait no not exactly it is rarely only
if you have that stated explicitly in
the contract or if you are a writer
director like the Coen brothers it's
close it's very close I've read the
script for Fargo the original screenplay
and what ended up on screen it's like
there may be a word changed once every
10 pages like it's almost word-for-word
and the thing is the Coen brothers are
really good they can do that um not
everybody can
so it didn't work and if you're handing
it off to a different director I just
wouldn't do that like I would try like
if I was that concerned about my
screenplay getting ruined I would try to
show up on set and coach them and yeah
well but I would my like here's my word
exactly because how you imagine it said
in your head could be said completely
different under the hands of a different
director in a cures and like you you
know maybe it sounded great on paper but
well so some of the actors there's this
great documentary on Netflix and talks
about I forget a lot say from page to
screen or something like I came here
what's called that's about writers in
Hollywood and they talk about just how
rarely what they wrote makes it to the
big screen like what they thought it was
gonna look like and be and what they say
where the story goes and everything and
they just changes so much so I think
there is this fear that they're gonna
take it and do whatever they want with
it and that does happen and that is a
shame but there's also if you go the
other extreme where everything has to be
you know exact then you're not allowed
to the movies not allowed to breathe
it's a write a book that's what you want
to do if you want to be exactly that way
and no changes and stuff you write a
book or to write the damn thing yourself
yeah um about you you movie there also
is a dark side to that we of course have
people like Lucas or Shama like oh yeah
there's a dark side of writing directing
or eerie mindful of that our uncle
always talks about how you should never
let a playwright direct a movie I don't
know if I'm that diehard but I know he's
talking about because there is a ton of
dialogue in movies there's a playwright
wordiness and you know films are still a
visual medium you know it plays it makes
sense you know you can do visual stuff
and mostly has to rely on the words uh
with film words are important but you
need it's still visual as well and yeah
if you look at a lot of them you'll see
that they are very much they're very to
even exercise three which I love and is
I would even cover you kind of a visual
movie there's still way too much talking
in that movie and it's obviously
directed by it or you are asking for an
invitation to the day and I love that
movie but even is not in the heart
there's only too much talking in that
movie um but how's your faith father
around Congo damn it uh but yeah
honestly this movie this is kind of one
of the more enjoyable ones - this was a
boy ass yeah this really would watch
we're just laughing
mostly for making that I only just got
bored with it during the action then
parts cuz like I I didn't believe the
the costumes that much I ending the X
was filmed extraordinarily well um in
the movie was so goofy that this is hard
time buying it but when it was just the
characters interacting oh it's like the
room set in the jungle yes don't
Ouisa it's really enjoyable silly um so
and I can't write in the book does she
go she doesn't go cuz like her fiance or
husband or something is there right she
she go is just cuz she was called in
right
yeah I thought god I remember that long
in there but but I could be wrong
oh shit well the book opened the same
way as the movie so that dude gets axed
oh yeah but I thought I camera via a
connection to her or not so it's one of
those things where it's like I feel like
it isn't the book they don't address it
that much i it's very much as I note I
want to say she was just sent on a
mission but I haven't read the book
since 1990 yes and for more--much Oh
kevie wrong we could be wrong but yeah
but yeah but again the way user area
even though 193 is before the movie came
out does the weight train races
characters that would be a big concern
even want to see you know that's just
not how he writes them honest and well
in every crane story somebody's getting
a divorce or is having relationship
problem yeah so any other common theme
is there is bickering about something
yeah so with this the whole idea of her
saying like you know you said we were
coming here because of this reason and
stuff I mean that is such I just can't
see a professional saying like you know
wait till we're we were coming here
because of this is like you're still
doing the same thing no reason we're
doing it's the same exact abusive I
don't care I'm just doing what my do
it's the same approach that Spielberg
did in Jurassic Park they were trying to
humanize the characters but
it's not Spielberg somehow got away with
it well first off you have Richard
Attenborough who's amazing in Spielberg
somehow was able to put enough of his
own soul into it that it it came off as
working I know some people are still
pissed by now he was supposed to be an
evil care that but it in the context of
the film it worked it it just doesn't
work here because the character was just
that just so is it whitey the Geiger is
so whiny
yeah and it does not such a bad ass in
the park yeah it does not do more Lenny
any favors and it yeah and it's a goal I
have a soul after only I don't see that
I don't care I was fine with her without
a soul like it it just didn't the
interactions with the characters were
not as such I felt like she needed to
have like this awakening um whereas in
Jurassic Park in the context of that
film it works easier because got the kid
you got the grandkids you got he has to
show everybody around like it in the
context of that movie makes sense to
soften the character makes things flow
to be very hard
yeah it doesn't flow in for going
international just you've gotta be yeah
it and she just creates distractions and
is annoying
doesn't do the actress any favors so um
I totally agree um and then for me the
biggest thing is the the ending with the
eighth guy with Amy going off with her
freaking brethren not in the book um
that's where I really lost it it's like
it was never her head apart and you
don't smell like chunk or no I'm not
even I'm not saying that I'm not gonna
get into animal behavior I'm just like
the book ended on a dark note it was a
dark book and I'm like they just Shmuel
stood up for no reason it's like ah
because amy got my nice characters that
none of their motivations would have
said that this was gonna happen um you
know it was more a statement in the book
if I got Jesus remember I think the
research was gonna get cut and then
though exactly was gonna happen to Amy
and his career was in question it was
very similar asset card where they're
just like well looks like a recent in
court in Costa Rica for you know number
of years that was like well life sucks
but it it works as the book and like it
that in the movie I just that was the
final nail in the coffin
like this is shit Amy go happy really
that was the final nail because no it
wasn't the final I'm just saying it to
me was the most insulting moment in a
series of insulting moments of like how
to adapt the book and I'm like now like
no you were very brave there no um but
yeah Tickle Me
Amy G is not the first appearance of
that a pin light event at my event yeah
go we brought aback quite a few times or
somebody's yeah exactly yeah so um yeah
that's our uh that's our real I won't
I went tell I will Tory so this the
first Campbell yeah Bruce Campbell uh I
think he's done this multiple times but
he believes YouTube video of it Brad
there's a youtube video that so look it
up at the just Bruce Campbell talking
about Congo try typing that and you'll
probably get it but he goes on this
whole spiel because people ask was like
why do star in shitty films like don't
you know it's gonna be shitty like
what's what's the matter with you and
he's like oh yeah okay you're you're an
actor alright here's their uh you're a
director right then okay okay and he's
like so uh we're gonna get Michael
Crichton for this project
alright you know big name on this is
gonna be great it uh you know it's gonna
be an action film where shoot this we're
gonna shoot this sucker in Africa Frank
Marvel like Academy award-winning
producer I think he was talking to this
kid as if he would have director but you
know so uh we're gonna get this
producing team behind this and all of
these great movies got major studio
behind it hey look at this
we're gonna get Laura Linney she's been
in something she's up because if she's
great uh you know who else are we gonna
get uh oh my God look at this Tim Curry
Tim Curry a legend uh you know hey
Oh Ernie Hudson uh ghostbusters you know
this I the cast list is going to go on
we're going to get some of the best
special effects teams in on this you're
going to believe these Apes are real
it's it's gonna be action-packed here
we're gonna throw a lot of money at this
and hey even better be movie sensation
Bruce Campbell's gonna have a bit part
in it since I like good movie too but
the kid just was like actually Isaac
congratula
did you just make a girl cared he's like
that's how it happens like it looks
great on paper but then every single
thing afterwards starts going wrong so
no I mean like like I always say I mean
making movies is not easy uh I always
say they're kind of something of a
little miracle every time one comes out
good because it's so many people and so
late thump rings I have to go into but
at least this was a hilarious ya know
even with actors uh doing this you know
like it was like yeah some actors I
can't think of any actor that has always
done a good movie it's not possible
because it's not just an actor's medium
it's you know it's a director as
producer it's all these people that come
in to try and make this film good and
he's all these people you're relying on
it's just it's impossible to have a
flawless record like every film be
perfect to test ik right here we go yeah
exactly I mean so it's one of those
things where um you know it's like well
how did this happen how did they it
happens to everybody it happens to every
actor director writer everybody uh so
even when we're like RRR is a critic as
well we do the real thoughts because you
know it's reality we know this is you
know that there's no real hey like I
really hate Frank Marshall even though I
never met the man it's like no we never
met these people uh we're just talk
about the film as it is and we know a
lot work goes into so many of these
films and yeah it's one of those things
where is he you're not gonna have a
flawless record but at the very least
you can have a film that is
entertainingly bad in this film it's
definitely that so I still try to
recommend oh if you want a great b-movie
like just hilariously like just piss
your pants funny you know I can IBS
b-movie this is like the congas equator
yeah definitely I think it's actually in
Mike Nelson's movie make a cheese book
so um it's definitely worth of you so
definitely uh with that said tickle Amy
fuck you